I know you love a Christmas miracle,
because you're as holly jolly as I am.
And here is one that I think you'll love from Australia.
The New York post reports that a woman returned home
to find a very awesome and Aussie surprise
in her Christmas tree.
Oh my goodness.
Now that is a little koala bear
just in the Christmas tree, surprise.
It's a fake tree, but the qualifier didn't know it
when he snuck into the house.
And the koala bear, it's fine,
rescuers took it and took care of it.
You know what I also loved,
I think one of my very favorite stories of 2020,
which is perfect for this Christmas Eve spirit episode
is Rockefeller which is the owl that they found
in the Rockefeller Center, big, famous Christmas tree.
Oh yeah?
So they brought in this kind of like shabby tree
that didn't look so hot.
But in it was Rockefeller, this little tiny owl.
I think that he's a perfect metaphor for this year.
He came inside of a tree that was not ideal,
but there he was.
There was beauty there.
There was beauty and a gentle little spirit.
And I am just like, I don't,
there was something about that story that just like
really resonated with me.
I do, I just, I give a hoot and.
There you go, you found it.
I think.
Owl knew you would.
Owl, owl love you, I do.
And you, you just, you stole my heart.
You really did.
You telling lies Drew.
I am.
And what I'd like to see is now a cage match
between Rockefeller and that koala.
Pay per view girl.
Right?
Okay.
And finally CNN business reports that Santa zooming
is a booming.
Okay, so Ross, there's this entire virtual industry
that has kicked off.
And I have to say I like this better than
the Santa behind plexiglass.
I always looked forward every year to going to the mall
to meet Santa as a kid, I actually thought like
what did kids do in 2020?
Well, they got it figured out.
Guess what Ross.
What?
We've got a Zoom incoming from the north pole right now.
Are you kidding me?
Yes.
Is Santa here?
Santa, is that you?
Oh my god.
You didn't tell me, hi Santa.
Merry Christmas.
I wanted to surprise you.
Merry Christmas Santa.
It's good to see, oh it's good to see you guys.
Hello.
And a big hello to Mrs. Claus,
how are you today?
Thank you so much.
Hi.
Drew I'm dorking out.
The brains behind the twosome is right here.
We're so happy to see you.
We're so happy to see you too.
And Ross, you know, is a big Santa fan.
Yes, I am a big fan.
You too Mrs. Claus.
Ross you have really grown from last year.
Oh my goodness.
Wow.
Thank you for noticing Santa.
You're such a big kid now.
All year.
Oh my gosh, yes, that's hard for you to do
but you've been good all year long.
He does know me, you do know me.
Santa and Mrs.
You are much improved.
And you too, you too.
Drew.
I have to tell you, I have to tell you Mr. and Mrs. Claus
that I have, I've worked very hard on myself this year.
And normally I feel like I'm top in the naughty list
as nice as I am to everybody.
I know I'm on that naughty list
for something or several things.
And this year I have really, really,
really worked hard on myself.
And I've tried to look at all my flaws
and go to work on them.
Well, it's really great that you clean your room
and you answer to the adults whenever they want you to help.
And we're really proud of you.
Very proud of you.
Thank you very much.
I love zooming them.
I love it.
Thank you, Mr. and Mrs. Claus.
It's such an honor and a pleasure to have you here.
You're making things okay for people and that is above
and beyond what you already do for everyone.
We get to look into the eyes of children and full of joy
and their shape in their eyes.
It's the greatest thing.
Just any touch of normalcy is the best.
A merry, merry Christmas to you both.
Merry merry Christmas.
Happy holidays, thank you.
Ho ho ho.
Mrs. Claus.
Bye, merry Christmas.
(upbeat music)